a few months ago the rumor mill exploded
regarding a collaboration between from
software the creators of Dark Souls and
george RR martin the writer behind Game
of Thrones A Song of Ice and Fire
today I'm making this video to tell you
that unlike season eight of Game of
Thrones these stories are actually
believable they're 100% true in fact
somehow I've actually known about this
for a couple of years from a source who
was familiar with the collaboration what
I didn't know was the following the game
is supposedly called great rune it's
inspired by Norse mythology an
open-world game that features horseback
riding and involves the player traveling
to various kingdoms to slay their rulers
and steal their unique powers these five
points are unconfirmed mind you but
considering that there's this steady and
reliable flow of rumors right now I'm
pretty confident in them confident
enough to get excited as hell so let's
dive into each point and see how much we
get wrong before the project is
confirmed at e3 in a couple of weeks
consider maybe following me on Twitch so
you can click the notification bell and
get notified a very three stream because
watching that together is always so much
fun let's briefly touch on George's
involvement we don't know exactly what
role he has in great rune other than
being a self-proclaimed consultant
however George is incredibly practiced
at world building his character arcs are
peerless and he's able to write that
witty flavorful dialogue to back all of
that up with him involved from
software's writing and concept should be
elevated to new heights but considering
George has books to write and a fanbase
of rabid readers snapping at his heels
I kind of doubt he has too much time to
devote to this title but at the very
least his name alone carries enormous
weight from a marketing perspective and
and I Namco is definitely going to play
that up so I honestly suspect this game
is going to reach a wider audience by
word of mouth
regardless of how much consulting George
has actually done one of the coolest
things about this collaboration is that
George commonly writes these obscure
hints and details into his stories to
the point where putting together some of
these subplots is like putting together
a puzzle and this is just like what from
software does while only a fraction of
fans will discover these clues naturally
this writing technique nourishes our
online culture of theory crafting and
discovery which is something that is
deeply important to communities like
ours the game is also supposedly
open-world which marks this huge
departure from from software's previous
level design style now every open-world
game is different some like Shadow of
the Colossus for example they use the
open world as a way to change the pace
as you head from major objective to
major objective some like The Witcher 3
spend years in development just so they
can fill the world with an immense
amount of detail and side quests one of
my favorite games zelda breath of the
wild it uses the open world to make your
journey feel like an adventure it has
numerous survival elements and visual
landmarks now considering that from
software isn't this enormous studio it
makes me wonder what design goals will
their open world fulfill our only clue
is that we will apparently traverse this
world on horseback which gives us an
idea of the scale of the map since
apparently it's big enough that we need
a horse to traverse it personally I'm
hoping that from software can innovate
on horseback combat that is always
something that's lacking in these
open-world games a horse is said to take
us between a multitude of kingdoms and
it's in these kingdoms that I think
we're going to see a return to the tight
complex level design that from software
is so good at according to the rumours
killing the leaders within these places
will grant you their unique powers which
empowers your character as you Forge
forward and go on conquering after
sekito I'm kind of hoping that they
learned a thing or two about
vil skill progression because while
sekito is incredible it definitely
dropped the ball with the combat arts
and character upgrades if these
open-world unlockable abilities are
meaningful and if there are RPG elements
in this game then it means that every
player will have a different experience
building their character and exploring
the world and this is a feeling that I
would love from software to deliver
while I'm sure each Kingdom is unique
the game is said to be steeped deeply in
Norse mythology and in a couple of weeks
when the game is likely revealed expect
themes of gods giants and heroes of
runes mythical creatures and I'm sure
there's gonna be you could wrestle the
world tree and all of its realms it's
gonna be fun to dive deeper into Norse
mythology but let's just wait until we
have some visuals to bounce off of and
until then I plan on exposing myself to
as much Norse inspired media as possible
if you guys have any suggestions share
them in the comments let's watch these
TV shows books and games that can teach
us a bit about the culture together
personally I'm gonna be starting with
God of War on Twitch for the first time
this week so click the link in the
description and come talk about great
ruin with me I'm excited remember to
click the notification bell to be
alerted of new videos and keep up with
great rune and I'll see you next time